I found someone I think can help me ah
someone who
to bring into the circle no I know what
I'm asking no who do we think it is
to you I was more at risk than I am I
know she's too young she's a teenage
girl but she's I mean we saw the fire
she had in Obi-Wan Kenobi she's gonna
defeat the Empire just by running
through the woods slowly yeah and
they're gonna run into branches and
trees
she'll take out every member of Red Hot
Chili Peppers if she has to it would be
great look out Anthony canis she's
coming for you next Chad Chad hall or
whatever his name is it looks like Will
Ferrell you're done
welcome back to New rockstars Star Wars
and or episode 4 brings our boy Cassie
and AKA Clem to aldani in a heist to
stop a space Nazi Payday the Imperials
hint at death star construction on
scarif and Luton masquerades as an
antique dealer while Senator Mon mothma
has a new operative to bring on board
but who is this operative is it Ahsoka
Tano is it bail or Ghana is it his
adopted daughter Princess Leia you'll
get your answers when he fixes and Dawn
door I like it uh this is WikiLeaks it's
our official after show to Andorra on
Disney plus I'm here with Tommy bechtold
what an episode uh Intrigue costumes
wigs affectations everything I needed
you know what I need I need I need uh I
need
um uh Stone Skarsgard to go full Mike
Myers on this thing I want him to play
like 15 characters throughout this
season of Andor like by the end of Andor
it's like he's played a Hut like he just
put it's on a giant rubber suit and he
plays like Tango the Hutt a a hood knees
dancing man it's just this one man show
he has all of his costumes on stage and
he gets he does his quick changes on
stage he's not hiding I love it so yeah
my breakdown of all the Easter eggs you
missed in this episode it's gonna be on
the channel uh next I think in a few
hours we'll see as quickly as we can
sometime today uh first though let's uh
talk about the the big juicy information
that was dropped in this episode and
we'll we'll recap what happened and
Tommy I don't know how you felt but like
you know we luckily got to see these
first four episodes early and you know a
lot of people had kind of a muted
response to the first three episodes and
I I just wanted to tell everyone like
just wait for episode four because
episode four is awesome like I loved how
much we explored the world and don't get
me wrong I love the first three episodes
I love the patience of it I love just
like the character development the
writing all of it was so great uh but
man episode four takes us Off to the
Races with uh yeah just learning how the
ISB Works Anton lesser just speeding
through that briefing was so cool I love
the the intensity of these Rebels on
aldani and how they all really don't
trust Cassian at all no uh it was so
cool
it kind of I mean it really parallels
some cool kind of like Earthbound Cinema
and Earthbound television of like yeah
the new guy coming in is a little too
convenient especially when he's a Swiss
army knife where they're like hey this
brand new guy is the answer to all of
our problems the whole savior thing is
usually a recipe for a disaster although
in this case we're fairly certain and or
is the hero so yeah I love it I thought
it was amazing I I love the first three
episodes as well I know sometimes these
shows especially one with the promise of
Andor where it's like there's 12
episodes this season it might take
people a little while to get to it but I
hope they get into it sooner than later
because they're missing out on the
weekly experience of of all of us seeing
it at the same time like other you know
kind of must-see TV so hopefully this is
the this is the week that gets them on
board hopefully yeah now episode four
begins with Lutheran and Cassian arguing
about the next step and we learned that
Cassian fought on mimban which is the
war effort that Han Solo and Chewie also
took part in and solo a Star Wars story
and I want to ask you Tommy do you think
Cassian Ander could have met Han Solo in
one of those trenches or uh Chewie
passing as he was like cuffed brought
into that uh whatever that Den that he
was in when they had to like fight each
other and they met or do you think they
were just ships in the night I think
Han Solo and Cassie and Andor would have
hated each other if they had met him
Chewbacca might have liked him but uh
there's no yeah if he had met Han Solo I
have a feeling that what they would have
been uh who shot first situation yeah
yeah
yeah
afraid of a cold-blooded killing so yeah
yeah uh wouldn't it be fun if uh if at
some point like you know we just see
some scar on his back it's just like a
Wookie SCAR or you know I don't know
yeah because uh Han and Chewie were
definitely steering clear the Rebellion
after that you know uh like they're
they're just in it for a Payday but you
know so is Cassie and Andor yeah exactly
they're very similar figures in that
regard yeah anyway so luthin says the
aldani mission is to rob the payroll uh
for an imperial sector I just love the
way that's introduced I love that that
is the mission uh because it's so
practical right it's not to blow
something up or to steal some weapon
it's just like piss off a lot of these
Imperial soldiers and desk workers were
not getting their payday because they're
so fat and satisfied all they really
want is their paycheck that's really the
secret power of the Empire is the fact
that they have the control the
pocketbooks of everybody yeah yeah for
sure I love this whole episode was chock
full of like bureaucratic letdowns and
people not doing their job we're only
doing 75 of their job like I understand
like that on the wrong hands and in the
wrong franchise this could be really
boring but it's fascinating to me to
have like things not working out because
people aren't doing their job having
actual consequences it's you know it's
it's not just getting uh doing a sex
mocking that away by like someone being
like oh it doesn't matter if no one did
their job I have this magic Crystal that
does everything it's like no yeah this
person didn't file their reports on time
and now we don't know what we're up
against so I like well we did get one
interesting perhaps magic Crystal this
episode a blue kyber crystal that
Lutheran gets casting is a down payment
he calls it a kuati Signet that
celebrates the uprising against the
recontinent Invaders I'm gonna go more
into what this means of the breakdown
but just so you know uh it it kind of
brings in a whole bunch of chunks of
Star Wars legends lore that you know
it's I love how every Star Wars Disney
Plus show has been doing this bringing
in little uh little references to things
that we just thought were from expanded
universe verse literature but it's
actually now Star Wars Canon the the
kuat is like it's another planet in the
core world that it's like an old um
um Merchant uh Dynasty I believe it's
just like from the ancient world uh and
it's like a matriarchal society uh it's
just really cool and then uh the ricotta
the recontins were like these old
conquerors that you know was believed
that they were part of inventing
hyperspace technology so the fact that
like this is now part of Star Wars Canon
again it's just so great uh and it's
from the ancient world and it's implied
that like is this his or is this
something that he swiped from his uh
antiques shop and he's just using it
right now and he has to return it
because otherwise he's like the guy who
works at the convenience store that
scratches lottery tickets on his break
but he's like I'll win enough to pay it
off so it'll be fine he's like I'll just
keep using these antiques as bribes but
I'll get it all back so it'll be all
right this episode also explores
Coruscant where we meet ISB officer
Dedra Miro another protect there's so
many characters on this show and I love
that we're exploring all different sides
of it just knowing we have 12 episodes
here yeah and the episodes are on the
longer side yeah which is just nice it
feels like we're getting to meet a lot
of different people here so Deja along
with a lot of other supervisors reports
to my new favorite character on this
show major partic as uh Anton lesser
from Game of Thrones they're all
reporting security updates across
various sectors and this guy is awesome
he's just like rapid fire getting
updates and just slapping people down
well you have another paperwork kids so
[ __ ] you and then just goes person to
person yeah and like he has this awesome
he's almost like house and house where
he's like wait uh treating illnesses and
we have no time to waste you know we are
in healthcare services that is our
industry yeah I love it he's like
someone reported to me the mission
statement well it's wrong
like if you want to cross through my
Gates you must marry one of my ugly
daughters Wait no that's another
franchise I apologize well in how how
methodical he is compared to how qyburn
is who kind of spoken riddles almost
he's just kind of a creeper who loved to
like work in his little experiments and
then he also played uh one of the
British prime ministers in the crown and
how like ineffective he was you know
I yes yes yes so this guy how he's just
a different form of methodical you know
and like he's kind of Master this domain
yeah you just but again pep talk to uh
to uh to the to the woman at the end
what's her name Nemo Nebo yeah fine Dean
Miro yes sorry I'm I'm new to the show
I'm learning it just like you guys it's
all good there's a lot of names he gives
her like a really nice like he's like
she's like he's like officers like you
are who were trying to hire so please
stop effing up right you yeah but
doesn't like uh it doesn't shut her down
he kind of he's clearly like grooming
her for uh for her skills uh but we you
know she learns that there's a lot of
Hoops you gotta jump through and uh
interesting that her jurisdiction is
this Imperial star path unit so that is
kind of our mystery box on this show is
there's a whole story here and she sees
that there's a major major redundancy in
the fact that like that was able to get
stolen from stearguard uh right like
that's a very big deal that we're gonna
keep pulling at that thread through Miro
uh and I'm excited to see what comes
next from that so meanwhile her rival
blevin dismisses Cyril Karn our boy
mosque our boy Hein yeah they all get
shut down uh all in three more really
it's now under Imperial control and I
think with the one of the most
fascinating things I've seen on Star
Wars is we follow him home humiliated we
think that might be hosnian prime or
some other planet where he meets his
mother played by Catherine Hunter aka
the next door neighbor from Harry Potter
who is a magic person in Disguise yeah
right or she's not she uh she's a squid
right yeah that's what it is she's a
witch who was born without magic anyway
amazing actress she slaps him and takes
them in the neighbors are like staring
like we never see this moment in Star
Wars and I I'd love that we get to see
that of just following someone they
don't get executed like we just follow
them home in disgrace it goes It goes to
what the the Tony Gilroy article we were
talking about on the Breakthrough
yesterday where he like asked the
writers on the show to kind of like let
go of their their fandom of Star Wars
and consider writing things a little
differently it's like yeah these are
things we've never these are signs we've
never seen before of these right this
type of Storytelling in in Star Wars for
sure yeah I mean every episode has been
doing this and but it doesn't feel like
contrary to Star Wars because like it's
we've we've come up to this interesting
debate around this show of like what is
Star Wars for people is it the stars or
is it the wars is it the is it the Jedi
in the lightsabers or is it the the
people fight hiding in the Trench Run
and in my opinion it's well it's both
there's no reason it can't be both but
like to me when I think a star was the
most exciting Thrill Ride I had was the
Trench Run it's the pilots it's the
Rebels on their missions it's the stakes
of the wars uh so that's what Rogue one
explored and that's what Andor is
exploring and like just seeing people in
a real war effort can be fascinating and
exciting you know absolutely and uh okay
so one of those efforts is on aldani
where Luton meets with the team leader
of el sartha makes her take on Cassian
AKA Clem as the team a member she
reluctantly agrees tells Clem that they
can't talk about Luther to the others
this has to look like it was part of her
plan all along they hide from Tie
fighters Glenn meets the rest of the
team including Charis arvil who's played
by even Moss Bacharach from the bear AKA
cousin for the bear Tamarind and Santa
and uh later Lieutenant Gorn who was
detected from the Empire who's kind of
making all this possible they plan to
break into this Imperial vault in an
Armory steal the payload ship it out on
a slow-moving freighter and really they
have a very narrow a window that you
have to use a sacred astronomical event
in which the planet passes through a
crystalline belt forming a meteor shower
across the sky as a cover for their
escape I love all the lore that we're
learning really the only reason they can
figure this out is because Lieutenant
gorgeous was able to learn from the
locals how much of a rare uh rare event
this is and they can use that to escape
but it's it doesn't seem like it's going
to be a likely a success or I don't
think all of them are going to make it
out alive no I would say I'm going to
bet on Andor and I'm not petting on
anyone else yeah pretty much I mean yeah
we'll talk about that in a bit I just
love how little they trust him and how
how scared all of them are yeah like
there's no uh wisecracking you know
everyone seems kind of like thrown they
they aren't confident and it just feels
so grounded and realist realism uh in
truth and I just love that and how much
they have to kind of Lie to each other
like again that's like a recurring theme
on this show of characters having to
like present this false narrative uh but
it is how life works you know people
have to just to avoid people from
defecting they have to like lie to them
just to keep them on board for just as
limited amount of time and it sucks but
that is how it works in these
high-stakes scenarios but perhaps the
the most interesting thing uh on this
episode is how luthum Returns the course
on it puts on this disguise he's got the
wig the fine ropes the jewelry changes
his posture and demeanor uh and he
assumes his double life as an antique
stealer with his partner Clea and greets
Senator Mon mothma the two-speaking code
until we learn that man makma is being
watched from all sides everywhere she
goes including her own driver just the
idea of seeing a new person in your
routine you have to suspect that the
Empire is now putting in and informant
just a very very fascinating wrinkle to
all this she's saying that she has
trouble getting funding for Lutheran she
wants to bring on a new person to their
Inner Circle Lutheran's like hell no
hell no we can't do that so that's
really who we're wondering about but we
follow mon mothma home as well to her
husband who without talking to her
planned a dinner party that includes
members of The Emperor's Inner Circle
including Sly more that's the bald and
barn you know yeah and then there's one
of the guys with the goofy hats who
followed him around and uh returned to
the Jedi that's who that is on the
invite list uh so
who's who of action figures that are
pretty rare yeah so yeah so she's really
worried about that uh so we're gonna
talk about what's coming next including
man Mama's new secret recruit why luthin
really needs Cassian on this Mission
particular and if any of these all Downy
Rebels will survive this Mission so
Tommy what's our question this week uh
uh I guess Eric I'll say no ifs and or
buts about it who is mon mafima's secret
recruit who indeed so this episode
brings us into the world of uh mon
mothma who's currently a senator in the
Imperial Senate on Coruscant she's
representing her home world of
chandrilla and we know from Obi-Wan
Kenobi that bail Organa from Alderaan is
in a similar position both of these
senators are trying to play both sides
and use their positions of power to
affect whatever goodness they still can
during these dark days while secretly
supporting Rebel insurgencies there was
that deleted scene from Revenge of the
Sith showing man meeting with bail
Organa after Emperor Palpatine Rose to
power and dissolve the Republic to form
the Empire but he kept the Senate intact
really just as like kind of a puppet uh
government so that like people still
felt like there was business as usual uh
but they met in secret and they plan to
do whatever they could to preserve
democracy that scene was Genevieve
O'Reilly's first time playing the role
and it was really from that one scene
that the producers of Rogue one decided
to bring her back which is really cool
because we're talking about like that
was over a decade and they brought back
the same actor I remember that yeah
where they were like this person have
like 15 years off or something like that
or not you know less than that but yes
yeah that's great good first she does a
great job she's awesome yeah yeah but
still about a decade to bring back the
same actor it just goes to show how much
they really liked what she did in that
world absolutely we have to wonder who
is in monmouth's current Circle along
with Lutheran Rail and who does Von
mappa want to add to it now the first
name that comes to mind of course is
bail or Ghana the thing is I'm just
wondering if Baylor got it might already
be a member of that particular Circle
let me think that whatever Rebel
operations Monmouth is a part of Bale
would probably also at least know of it
as well unless unless and this is
something that and or the series is
introducing to us that they have to be
so secretive in clandestine that they
might not even know what each other are
working on at this point in history how
many meetings do you think bail and man
can have with each other because they're
both senders who are both being closely
watched can they really meet that often
at this point I have to wonder if Bill
Organa may have his side of the
Rebellion that he's working on we know
he's in touch with certain people we
know he's in touch with Ahsoka Tano that
that uh I don't know if my mama would
even know at this point in history that
Ahsoka Tano is like a still alive and B
like helping out with the cause I still
think Baylor Ghana is a likely
possibility if any Cameo shows up at all
which might be a very slim possibility
in general just we know how Tony Gilroy
is approaching this but like we do get
mention of someone I think Baylor Ghana
would be likely because we just saw him
on Obi-Wan Kenobi and this show is going
to explore more of the Imperial Senate
uh so it's possible we get a Jimmy
Smith's Cameo it just seems like it's
not a very exciting possibility it just
is possible I just don't know if that
would be someone where Luth is like no
not him because really I feel like I'm
on Martha's operations would have
proceeded sure fail than with Lutheran
but I don't know I've got I've got a
rogue pitch go go for it maybe it's uh
time for a couple people to speak man to
man to Calamar maybe it's time for a
certain Admiral Akbar to enter the fold
I mean he's already established as an
admiral in A New Hope right he's already
established as I don't know I don't know
what the timeline is because we have
Admiral Radice who is uh who is the one
who oversees the Battle of scarif I
don't know
bar he's alive at this point I don't
know where he is in the moncala power
yeah I'm just saying you never know
I think it's possible I want to see some
more aliens I've seen enough human faces
let's get smelly into this if someone
comes in and goes it's a thwa then we
know I'm right
he may be a teenager at this point so as
far as he's concerned it's all a fad
he's just a little calamari now he's
just a little ring it's a fact
Targaryen over there on moncala but it's
all water so it just dissolves Jesus
more targaryens fell off that window
than any uh than any uh baratheons eh
yeah I think so thousands of targaryens
died that day but uh
but we mentioned Ahsoka Tano and uh
so could it seems like that would be the
one that Tony Gilroy is like no we're
not doing that [ __ ] on the show we're
not bringing in a bunch of cameos but
that would be the one that like it just
depends on how much lucasfilm is gonna
have a role and who this is or if it's
just doing a Gilroy doing it but Ahsoka
Tano was brought in by Baylor Ghana at
some point during this period as a rebel
spy on the fulcrum Subspace seat
frequency assuming we get more news
about the Ahsoka spin-off Series this
fall as more episodes of Andor come out
this could be a good place for us so
could at least get mentioned
um I think it would be too early for
Harrison Doula or any members of the
crew the ghost to come up on the show
just because mon matma joins up with
Hera in an episode of rebels and that's
not until later after Senator matma
Parts ways with the Senate becomes a
fugitive following her speaking out
against the Gorman Massacre actually if
you listen closely she did mention the
Gormans in this episode that she's
already kind of worried about what's
happening to them she said invite some
Gorman see how they think about it yeah
yeah right yeah I have a theory that my
mother might want to bring someone into
the circle that bill they're gonna know
so it might not be aware of how much
that person knows about the rebel
operations and that person is a young
pre-teen Leia or Ghana
uh now Leia at this point has started to
become aware at least suspicious of her
parents support of the Rebel causes Bale
and Bria tried their best to keep Leia
in the dark for everything they were
doing
um just for her protection eventually
according to literature from this period
Leia figures it out and they bring her
into the circle that's why uh you know a
couple years after this
um Bale goes I will trust her with my
life but would uh would man Mac would go
over Bales had to bring Leia into the
fold well Leia and Monmouth have a
relationship uh Monmouth is kind of a
mentor to Leia at this point in history
because Leia spent some time in the
Senate it kind of uses her as an
apprentice to learn the ways of
statecraft uh so this is like a big time
for Leia we could learn that the person
that mon Mata wants to just bring into
the fold could be could be Leia Organa
now at this point in history would they
have a DH Carrie Fisher or would they
bring in the actress who played Leia in
Obi-Wan Kenobi it just kind of easier up
a little bit I think it would be the
latter but I just don't know I don't
based on the reaction to Young Leia and
Obi-Wan Kenobi A lot of people felt that
that character was unnecessary and kind
of silly in the way that she was running
away from Fleet uh but I think this
could be uh like something that uh an
interesting art I like it I'm on board
with it Eric I I think yeah I also think
you could cast you could cast like a 16
year old or a 15 year old actor oh sure
in that role that looks like you know
kind of as a cross in the middle so why
not bring in a whole new Princess Leia
all you have to do is do the hair up in
like a specific style and people be like
oh that's Leia you know and play the
theme now do you think that this would
be something that Baylor Ghana does with
his consent or something that Bale
wouldn't know about my thinking is that
bail would be like yeah it's time for
the daughter to figure out what's going
on yeah especially with him knowing her
involvement and everything you know like
him knowing her true history and stuff
you know it's like there's a lot of
Destiny in that so yeah all right so we
want you guys please to go check out new
rockstarsmerch.com for our two new
Cassie nandor shirts inspired by the
show we've got the Andor Signet symbol
inside the Death Star and of course we
have the and I'm gonna say this right
Rebel scum shirt no mispronunciation
needed so check those out thanks as
always for visiting
newrockstarsmerch.com all right Tommy uh
why do you think Lutheran is pushing
Cassian onto this Mission I know he
needs like you know more people to help
out with it he wants it really to go
well but it seems like he's grooming
Cassian for a specific job on this
Mission he's not really clueing in
valsartha that much on it right what do
you think's really going on there well
it seems to me as if Luther knows that
this is a very very very highly unlikely
uh everyone makes it out style Mission
so I think this is maybe perhaps a next
level in Lutheran's testing of Andor to
see you know I mean obviously there's
bigger and more grandiose plants to take
out the Empire right like they
understand it's not just going to be
stealing a few payroll crates of pay so
I to me I think he's like let me put him
in a situation that is almost impossible
the Kobayashi Maru of the Star Wars
Universe if you will an unwinnable test
although there will be human lives so
people are abuse living creatures killed
human and otherwise in this Mission most
likely I I think this is just like this
is like to hear him he's like he passed
the the uh the first test now let me
give him this incredibly difficult test
if he passes this I can give him a huge
huge Mission I don't know why I did the
Donald Trump hand symbol for you it's
hard not to it's hard yeah he ruined the
word huge bigly he ruined it bigly am I
reading into uh a relationship here
between Lutheran and Vel like does it
seem like they might be father and
daughter there the way he yells at her
to look at you wanted to lead doesn't it
seem like there might be a relationship
there yeah yeah it does seem like
there's definitely more it also feels
like she's protecting the other
Rebels from her or she's blocking them
from her true relationship with Lutheran
as well right like she doesn't even
really bring him up to them um
do we know that they know he exists even
or like you know they must know someone
exists she might be worried that like
they're gonna not trust her if it's just
Daddy's girl who got this gift sure you
know that makes sense yeah speaking of
This Crew do you think any of these
Rebels will survive this Mission I mean
they're gonna kill that little kid
they're not kidding they're definitely
going to kill that kid like he's gonna
be like do it for me and or and then
Andor is going to be in his head just
counting credits he's like wait if I
take his amount of credits too that's a
pirates game here yeah he's very like
okay I mean possibly no I think
everybody dies but Andor I'm gonna go
with that I think everybody yeah
honestly I'm feeling the same way I
think cousin's gonna die I think Belle's
gonna die and then later after she dies
that's when we find out that it was
Cassie or that was Lutheran's daughter I
think because he's gonna be like where's
Val where's Val uh she didn't make it so
they'll just being that depressing yeah
all right so the fact that we follow
Cyril home do you think I mean what's
next for him is he going to join the
Empire is he going to play some other
role is he going to like go even harder
and try to redeem himself and make
things even worse for everybody I think
there's going to be some sort of
breakthrough in that case that brings it
to the attention of the Empire again and
he's going to get a Redemption shot in
an empirical uh Redemption shot and be
brought in as an imperial officer I
think he comes back as an imperial
officers my guess yeah I think that uh
we're gonna learn of like some other new
horrible faction of people who like
serve the Empire or like do things their
own way you know that work outside the
law of the Empire that are just like
even worse probably that Linus mosque
right is that his name is like he'll be
like there's another group we can join
and they're even more for the cause than
us it'll be great everything they do is
about killing it'll be wonderful I think
he's going to commit some horrible War
crime that's just something horrible
horrible I mean maybe he'll end up being
good I think it'd be kind of boring if
he ended up being good personally yeah I
would have sold it because we already
have a bunch of like noble criminals on
this show yeah we don't need that like
andor's Ark is kind of Redemptive in a
way and he's such a broken per insecure
person already he's perfect for like to
become like a fanatical Imperial officer
who's like he does you know just kills
indiscriminately and it's like he's the
one that like when kylo Ren's like kill
all the villagers he's like doesn't even
hesitate to start shooting he's like
already dead I already killed him oh you
wanted me to do that no good great
perfect well again my breakdown of all
the Easter eggs that you might have
missed in this episode episode 4 will be
coming out later today thank you so much
for watching this after show follow me
at EA Vos follow Tommy at Tommy Bechtel
follow new rockstars subscribe to
WikiLeaks wherever you get your podcast
thank you so much for watching it and we
we have spoken
foreign